Speaker 1: A lying Republican, Congressman
George Santos, was met with some brutal heckling,
brutal heckling at LaGuardia Airport when
he arrived yesterday. He faced questions,
continuing to face questions about more of his
lies. Now it turns out that he appears to have you
know, I don't know the right terminology. I don't
know if he was a drag queen. Like, I don't know.
Dressed in drag was a drag. What I do know is that
Republicans for a year have been saying that drag
queens are one of the greatest threats to America
and our children that they have ever seen from the
left. And it turns out George Santos appears
to have also dressed in drag. He seems to be
admitting it. He's just saying I was having fun.
Okay. We'll get to that on the bonus show. Anyway,
he arrives at LaGuardia Airport and is immediately
swarmed. Take a look at this department.
Speaker 4: This is how you take
it from here. You call my office,
right? Which I didn't respond to any e-mail.
And I'll take care of what I've already told
you specifically in that I will sit with
you. Okay. If you approach it throughout
the property, you know, I.
Speaker 1:
Call my office. Oh, I did.
They don't write back to me.
Speaker 4: The. Look at this. You
know, Avery, I know, like, you
guys recognize that I'm. I'm tired of it. Yes,
they have. I told them I want you to meet me
last night for a meeting, and I go back and.
Speaker 1: Look at all the work he's doing.
Speaker 4: Congressman, who
did you speak with? Classified.
Speaker 1: Classified, I. Oh, that's genius. So
I looked into that. My understanding is that who
he meets with is not classified. It's just
private, you know? And this is again. These
people have no business in these role. It's
classified. Now, you might just not give us
the names of everyone you met with, although it
might actually be public record. I don't know.
Speaker 4: Look, guys, I wish you guys
well. I'm going to go in an elevator and.
Speaker 1: I wish you guys well.
Speaker 4: And go home. No more it.
Young and I had to find out.
Speaker 1:
So there he is. Asked about the drag queen
stuff. He says, I was young and I had fun.
Speaker 4: To make for having a life. How about
the $700,000 at the World Trade Center got? Look,
this is how you can look in the mirror.
Speaker 1: Was your mother at the World
Trade Center on 911 is related to the
fact that Santos has told two different
stories about when his mother died.
Speaker 4: I love your guy who keeps
following me and plays like they could do
a good job keeping you guys off your back.
Congressman Rohrabacher, who was governor
for the entirety of Victoria, how are you?
Speaker 1: All right. So then he gets himself into
an elevator. Here is a nice one. CBS two talked
about this. They are now, as a matter of
fact, just introducing him as a disgraced
congressman, which I have to tell you I love.
Speaker 3: We begin with breaking news tonight,
disgraced Congressman George Santos.
Speaker 1: He's been he's been in
office a week and they're already referring
to him as disgraced congressman back in town.
Speaker 3: Our cameras were there when he
landed at LaGuardia late this afternoon. Yeah.
Speaker 4: Well, you know what
I. I mean, last night, as you.
Speaker 3: Heard in the background there, someone
yelling con artists walk through baggage claim.
He ignored many of the questions from
reporters, but did say he's working for
his constituents. He also criticized the media.
Speaker 4: I wish you guys well. I'm going to
go inside. And I have spoken with the voters.
I've been in district the whole week. I've been
taking constituent calls. I've received federal
grant applications for projects in the district,
and I look forward to serving the people. The one
thing I'll say is the media and we've received
plenty of complaints about you guys stacking up.
Speaker 3: The embattled lawmaker is facing more
scrutiny over his past. Santos said his
mother escaped the South tower on 911,
but a researcher obtained immigration records
showing she was in Brazil at the time. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Anyway, we are going to have to stay
on this, because I really do fear fear. And I'm
increasingly thinking that he is just going to
stick it out no matter how humiliating it is. He
wants to be a big boy congressman, and he is going
to just try to avoid the pressure on him to resign
for now. And he may well get away with it, because
I'll be honest, I don't know how long. Like,
eventually I think eventually we'll get to
the end of his lies that can be uncovered.
And so then it's just recycling stories and
saying we still think he should resign. The
story will go away. So lets us keep the pressure
on media outlets and other members of Congress to
keep the pressure on Santos. But I'm worried
that this may be starting to lose steam and
he may be able to end up serving those two
years, which would be absolutely horrible.